are you [__] kidding me you want to
change the world with one post a week we
really want to change the world we've
started a movement healthy happy and
free we want to change the world and
have the world be really healthy happy
good we have a movement called all okay
I want everyone to be all look how much
content are you making um so that's
that's our thing we are we are really
working hard we just added another
person to our team how much content are
you putting out
um
how many posts a day come out from this
Mission tell you the truth one post a
week right now
um yes are you [__] kidding me got
our hands in too much stuff and we're
trying to simplify what the [__]
if I say something you believe in
meditation uh breathing techniques okay
let's talk about breathing techniques
you guys can make 47 videos in a month
about breathing techniques you've got
the right intent yeah but something's
holding you back are you scared of
judgment are you scared of having not a
lot of followers you're scared of what
people are gonna think like you gotta
that's what we gotta work on here but
can you see how fast we made that video
yeah yeah you have time if you really
want to change the world yes